voilà et c'est cette faute au
passage vous vous êtes maquillée de bleu
qui illustre un ouvrage qui vient de
sortir que vous connaissez pas je qui
est signée jean douchet s'appelle tout
simplement nouvelle vague sont tous les
documents qui racontent la nouvelle
vague les deux photographique bien
entendu mais aussi les textes et
notamment il ya beaucoup de 7 à céder
aux pilotes de lire les critiques
certains des films et notamment sur par
exemple à bout de souffle bah c'était
pas unanimes 1 à nantes où on croit
toujours que à bout de souffle a été
encensé et pas du tout ça a été témoin
de vous l'offrir brillante immersive et
alors et s'était attaquée beaucoup et
moi même je me faisais attaqué aussi
donc c'est avec le temps que les gens
mais ça très très bien quand vous avez
détourné bout de souffle est ce que vous
aviez conscience de tourner un film
qu'elle est très important dans les
mêmes est très triste orange est tout à
fait honnête avec vous mais pas du tout
je m'amusais beaucoup parce que quand
c'est que vous amusez vous n'arrêtez pas
vous auriez rigoler aussi parce que
quand même on tournait n'y avait pas de
sens il y avait la caméra matchs ont été
serrés ya encore des petites voitures
déposent poussé caméras et des plans qui
là dedans l'ajustement les rôles
tribunes on descendait sur les
champs-elysées comme ça et je pensais
que ce film ne sortirait pas alors
j'étais d'autant plus décontractée
sincèrement non pas que je prenais
godard pour un imbécile ou un type qui
n'avait pas de talent mais moi le petit
cinéma que j'avais fait il y avait du
son il y avait des sages et la scripte
il avait foutu à la porte y avait pas de
script il n'y a pas pas de son témoin il
y avait rien je me disais ce film là ne
sortira pas la nouvelle vague on en
parle encore bien entendu c'est antoine
de bec qui vient de publier la nouvelle
vague portrait d'une dune jeu des c'est
donc un essai là aussi avec des photos
et il dit ceci parce que quand même
c'est un succès considérable et où ça va
voulait que beaucoup mais il dit le
cinéma tendent un miroir à la société il
était déformant mais cela n'avait rien
d'exceptionnel ce qu'il a été ces la
force avec laquelle une génération a
voulu s'y voir souvent s'y reconnaître
parfois s'y opposer et je crois qu'il a
vraiment raison ce n'était pas unanime y
avait aussi des gens qui ne sait plus
bien chez flammarion
il ya des gens qui étaient choqués par
le film inquiéter un peu ardu et vous
avez montré pierrot le fou aussi mais
pierrot le fou a déclenché aussi bbb une
sorte de large chez les gens c'est
beaucoup après on m'a dit pourquoi vous
ne tournez pas avec godard mais à
l'époque on me disait pourquoi vous
tournez rigolard c'est c'est vrai ce que
je veux dire car j'ai fait pire au loup
beaucoup de producteurs de cinéma
mondial sept fous pour pouvoir retourner
avec ce type